hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's almost time to dust off techno
dinosaur Terminator a lie as the first
DLC and only DLC for that matter for
horizon zero dawn it's almost upon us it
goes by the name the frozen wilds if you
haven't played horizon zero dawn
well I'll simply say it you are missing
out but I'm not here to throw peer
pressure at you I'm here to tell you
seven things you should know about
horizon zero dawn the frozen wilds so
straight off the bat where the heck is
it taking place a brand spanking new
area set if you haven't guessed already
by the title in the snow-covered frozen
north just beyond the boundaries from
the main map if we apply a little
investigative reasoning we can surmise
the original game took place around
Colorado with many landmarks backing
that up a lie ventures into Utah and
Arizona to the frozen wild DLC has our
hero heading north into Wyoming and once
again by the landmarks we've seen in the
trailers it looks pretty safe to say
we're going to Yellowstone National Park
in our post-apocalyptic journey with a
new area comes new enemies to battle and
new wildlife to inhabit the area's the
rock breaker linked Hawks snap Mars and
other machines return in the frozen wild
but it's this fire-breathing death bat
hound figure that has my attention we
could check the trophy list to figure
out its real name but I think by a
breathing death but hound thing has a
nice ring to it this beast is all about
fire and leaves a flaming trail behind
it which will probably force us to think
tactically in the heat of the battle see
what I did there anyway well he may be
surrounded by a wall of flames if we
aren't careful especially on the harder
difficulties with this expansion we can
expect a new story bridging from the
core narrative and potentially adding
more details to that story a
brand-spanking-new tribe with their own
culture and survival elements to
consider - the bond between a log and
the other characters she meets has
always been a huge focus of horizon zero
dawn and the expansion is no different
than the exquisite storytelling should
continue all the way through this DLC
I'm not here for glory I'm here for the
mountain for answers then you must face
the beast of the gods it
a new culture a new way of life oh and
even a new currency - for this
additional area so if you've been saving
up to buy all the items right away you
may need to grind a little first new
armor and weapons are here to discover
and master the devs have kept their
cards close to their chests on this one
but they have confirmed two new skill
lines to add to the three we already
have access to only one little thing has
been slipped so far and that's the
ability to heal our mounts halos level
cap has been increased from 50 to 60 so
there's at least 10 new skill points to
utilize and invest if you've been
playing horizon zero dawn on the new
increased difficulty level we're still
waiting on information about our level
carrying over if I have anything
confirmed I'll pin it below in the
comments we know where in the world this
is taking place but what about when we
know this new area of the map will be
unlocked after about 10 hours of
standard play in the original title
therefore for me that's a confirmation
that these events will indeed happen
before the games ending the original
story was tied up perfectly and to
trample on that now would detract from
it massively so instead we have the
frozen wild as a concurrent story in my
opinion it's the right decision by the
way I'll link a story recap at the end
of this video just in case you need a
refresher of a large travels so far is
the killing over this was just one
battle of all with this expansion comes
a new copy of the entire game which has
everything you could ever hope for
included the complete edition comes with
both the main game and the frozen wilds
obviously a digital art book an
exclusive ps4 theme a storm ranger
outfit at bow avenue Trailblazer outfit
and Cooling bow a traveler pack a trader
plaque and a keeper pack that's a lot of
[ __ ] in terms of price it's twenty
dollars or twenty euros for the DLC and
that's about sixteen pounds in the UK
and fifty dollars for the complete
edition over here in England I've seen
it retail for as little as thirty four
pounds
so there we have it horizon zero dawn
sworn and only DLC will land on November
the 7th are you grabbing it oh and if
you her any of you thinking about
picking up Monster Hunter soon guess
what a lie will be a playable character
on the ps4 version of Monster Hunter
world
[Music]
oh I can't get enough a law in my life
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time